>>Joel Constable: Hello everyone. I'd like
to welcome you all to another talk in our
Leading@Google series. My name is Joel Constable
and I work in Leadership Development as part
of Google.edu. And I'm excited today to introduce
our newest speaker in the series, Joseph Grenny.
Over the past 20 years, Joseph has taught
and advised more than 100,000 leaders on all
continents.
He is the co-author and contributor to eight
different books, including three New York
Times bestsellers, “Influencer: The Power
to Change Anything", "Crucial Conversations:
Tools for Talking when the Stake are High”,
and “Crucial Confrontations: Tools for Resolving
Broken Promises, Violated Expectations and
Bad Behavior.” Today, Joseph will be discussing
his newest book, “Change Anything: The New
Science of Personal Success.” Pease join
me in welcoming Joseph.
[applause]
>>Joseph Grenny: Well, let's see. [pause]
I'll use that so it'll carry me to the back.
Do you hear me OK back there? OK, good. Well,
thank you. It's exciting to be here and this
is the week that the book launches. So those
of you who do product releases on a regular
basis, this is our product release and it's
exciting to be able to share some of what
we've been working on for the past few years
with you.
My goal is pretty ambitious. I want to accomplish
something that you may not think possible
in an hour. I'd like you to leave with a new
brain. So, my understanding is that you arrived
at Google 'cause you got a pretty good one
already. But I want you to leave with one
that is capable of something entirely new.
And in order to accomplish that, I'm gonna
need you to get a little bit more engaged
than you usually would. So, you're gonna need
two things, a writing instrument of some sort,
electronic, manual, whatever you got. So if
you get something handy, I'm just gonna have
you do a couple of very brief, very focused
little tasks.
The second thing you're gonna need is a learning
buddy. So if you look to your left, right,
front, and back and find a reasonably intelligent
person.
[laughter]
Buddy up. Then you'll have everything you
need for this to be an extremely useful experience
to you.
[audience chatter]
Great.
OK, good. So you all got a learning buddy
and a writing instrument, I think you're in
good shape. Let me set the context for the
topic you're to start with and then I'll get
you busy here. So first of all, let me ask
you to raise your hands if you identify with
any of these scenarios.
So first of all, how many of you know more
about wellness, relationships, parenting,
financial planning, than you currently do?
How many of us fall into that category? So
we all have knowledge that exceeds our current
practice at times in some areas of our lives
that affects our personal lives. But let's
talk professionally as well.
How many of know more about leadership, career
management, professional effectiveness, than
we currently express in our habits as well?
So we identify with that also. So the theme
here is, that very often, understanding is
insufficient. It's what we can translate into
habits in our lives. How many of you know
other people whose primary obstacle in their
career, or life, is their own behavior?
Any of us know people like that?
[laughter]
Don't point at them. [laughs] Just, I'm asking
you to think about them. Finally, how many
of us know an organization, not the present
one, but how many of us know an organization
that could be significantly more successful
if people would just behave a little bit differently?
We encountered that same dynamic. So this
is the topic for today.
The topic is that the greatest challenge we
face frequently is not just the learning.
It's the translation of what we understand
into habits, into behavior, in our lives.
The primary reasons, I contend, that individuals
fail to live up to their potential often isn't
the lack of ideas. There are a lot of ideas
out there. It's a lack of behavior.
It's a lack of being able to translate that
into practice. The primary reasons organizations
often fail is not because we don't have a
great strategic direction or a good product
concept. It's the execution of it. It's developing
habits and behavior that are going to support
the leveraging of that concept. So let me
step you back for just a second.
We started 25 years ago together studying
human change. About five years ago, said we
wanna look at just the individual. So we're
gonna separate you today out from your organizational
context and say, "What about just you, personally?"
And we found, as we talked with HR professionals,
for example, across the world that there are
a whole lot of Thomas's.
Now this is a puzzling thing because here's
Thomas. Thomas was described as one of the
most loyal employees in his entire organization.
He was described by colleagues as somebody
you'd really wanna have at your left or right
in a crisis. When things get bad, this is
somebody who rolls up his sleeves and really
gets the job done.
But secretly, behind his back, his colleagues
would also tell you that the guy can’t manage
to a schedule. When there's not a crisis,
you can't count on him to get something to
youon time or on budget or on spec. So that's
Thomas. Now, Thomas got a new supervisor and
his new supervisor decided she was going to
start coaching him in a way that nobody had
prior to this.
So in year one, in his performance review,
she said, "You really need to learn to manage,
to be a little bit more predictable." And
he was very motivated to change that. So he
started working on it, but was unsuccessful.
Year two, she said, "You really need to work
on this, or you'll lose your job. This is
important, Thomas. Pay attention."
In year three, he lost his job. So this was
an interesting scenario to us, because here
you've got a guy who has incredible motivation
to change. I mean, your job is at risk, right?
You really do wanna change, but doesn't change.
And that's what we've been studying for the
past five years. By show of hands, how many
of you believe that you have enormous control
over your own behavior?
How many of us believe that that describes
us, that we have great control over our own
choices? My purpose today is to convince you
that you don't.
[laughter]
So what I want you to get, and if I'm successful,
what you'll walk out understanding is that
you have a heck of a lot less control over
your behavior than you think you do, and that's
why these Thomas stories are so frequently
the case. Now let me take you to a whole different
scenario. So I want you to meet Michael Vitali.
About four years ago, when we started the
line of research that led me to talk to you
today, we met a whole number of people--I'll
describe them in just a moment-- like Michael.
I want you to listen to his story, here. Michael
had a change challenge.
[plays clip]
>>Michael Vitali: Well, my story starts back
when I was a very young man. I was hopelessly
addicted to drugs and alcohol. I got in serious
trouble, everything from legal trouble, financial
trouble. I lost everything that I owned, all
my personal possessions, my car, all my CDs,
everything that was important to me in terms
of my material possessions--gone.
Relationships. I lost a woman that I thought
I was gonna marry and she couldn't handle
my alcoholism. My family, I lost the love
and respect of my family and the people that
mattered to me. And I wound up morally, spiritually,
emotionally bankrupt.
[end clip]
>>Joseph Grenny: So Michael ends up in prison
in Arizona for a 12 year sentence, due in
large measure to some of these habits in his
life. And so, when I listened to Michael's
story, I had to ask myself the question. This
is a 20 year story, right? This wasn't a fast
thing. Thomas's story was a three year long
saga as well.
The question I put to you is, at what point
do think Michael wanted to change? At what
point do you think Thomas wanted to change?
You see, the challenge here is, that all of
us believe that if we just want it badly enough
that we have control over our behavior. So
we ought to be able to change.
We're all caught in what we'll call later,
the "will power trap." We believe that will
power is the predictor of our capacity to
change. And yet, when you look at our lives,
we find that many of us have problems of the
physics that you see in Thomas's and Michael's.
What I found is there were 20 rock-bottoms
in Michael's 20 year story.
There were many, many, many points along the
way that he said, "I've gotta change this.
This hurts too bad. I've lost this. I'm gonna
change. I've lost this. I'm gonna change."
But then he didn't change. The definition
of a change problem that I'd like to propose
is a situation where you know you ought to
change.
In fact, you even want to change, but you
don't change. And all of us have those. All
of us have some area in our lives where we're
being kept from something that we'd really
like to achieve in our career, or in our relationships,
or in our personal life, because we're unable
to overcome that kind of a dynamic.
And what does it cost? Well, the fact that
we can't handle this particularly well affects
us in our employment situations. 87 percent
of employees in one of our studies suggested
that they'd suffered economically because
of their own behavior in the workplace that
they were unable to change.
Financially, we suffer. When we ask how many
people feel like you’re on track for an
eventual retirement, about one in five say,
"I'm where I ought to be." Relationships are
the same. It turns out that even those who
seek advice rarely benefit from it. I can
listen to a counselor that says, "Do this
differently and your relationships will go
better." But our capacity to absorb that into
our lives is fairly low.
And finally, you look at health. Now, I want
you to think about this from the will power
perspective again. What a remarkable statistic.
Ninety percent of those who wind up in the
hospital for coronary bypass surgery because
habits in their lives have led them there,
are back to the exact same behavior within
just a couple of years of going under the
knife.
Could you define or design a more motivating
opportunity for somebody than open heart surgery?
I mean, these are people leaving the surgery,
who want to change, know they should change,
but don't change. So what I wanna do is challenge
our naive assumption that just wanting it
is what it takes to change. That hitting rock
bottom is the predictor of our capacity to
break out of this.
So about four years ago, we threw a question
out to the universe. The question was, "Are
you struggling to change some habit in your
life?" And five thousand people raised their
hands and said, "Yeah. Yeah, I am." And then
we followed their stories over a period of
years and said, "Who succeeds and who fails?"
About 4400 of those failed, or at least their
failure's in motion. So they're still struggling,
but haven't conquered whatever the behavior
changes that they were attempting to bring
about. A few hundred, however, succeeded.
And so what we wanted to do was to say, "What
can you learn that differentiates, and even
predicts, who ends up in Category Two versus
Category One?"
Well, there were three principles, two of
which I'll have a chance to elaborate on a
little bit today. Three principles that had
a remarkable predictive power to them. In
fact, we later published some of this research
in the MIT Sloan journal and what we were
able to demonstrate is that the practice of
these three principles predicts at ten times
who succeeds versus who fails.
Those who practice these principles are ten
times more likely to find themselves changed
in a profound, measurable, sustainable way
versus those who don't. So that's what I'd
like to share. Here's the first concept. The
first, most important thing to get into our
heads when we looked at those who succeeded
at change was they broke out of what we came
to call the "willpower trap."
The willpower trap is sort of the assumption
that this is the mode that change works in.
So, we crunched a whole lot of our numbers,
developed a really sophisticated computer
simulation to demonstrate how you and I tend
to approach change, and here's what resulted.
[sounds of straining and grunting]
Millions of dollars, folks. There it is. [laughs]
[laughter]
How many of you identify? ]laughs] So we've
all been on that, right? When we tend to approach
change, we see it as this struggle against
some mighty opposition. And as long as we
dig our heels in and hold against it, we can
stay over in the good category. But as soon
as you relax your grip, you get dragged back
in the other direction.
Well, here's your first assignment. So, with
your learning partner, I wanna share with
you a little laboratory experiment we did
with 11 and 12 year old children. We wanted
to subject them to a variety of sources of
influence and see how they'd respond but then
also see if they were aware of what was going
on.
So, with your partner, I'd like you to watch
the experiment and afterwards, just articulate,
what are the implications for change in this
study? So if what we're suggesting here is
true, what are the implications for how you
and I think about change? Here you go. This,
by the way, was conducted by my son, Hyrum,
for a Science Fair project. So, you'll meet
him in a moment.
[plays clip]
[music]
>>Hyrum Grenny: Most of us are just one habit
away from being much happier, healthier, or
wealthier, but we can't change. And if you
ask the average person how much control they
have over their own behavior, they'll tell
you, "A lot." If that's true, then what's
our problem?
Why is it that almost all of us know we should
change some habit. [grunting sounds] We even
want to change some habit. [grunting sounds]
But we don't change that habit. Conventional
wisdom is that we just lack the willpower.
Well, I wanted to find out. I wanted to see
if success is all about personal motivation,
so I gave a group of 10 year old kids a chance
to earn 40 dollars. All had big plans for
the money once they left my lab.
>>Boy #1: Well, I was wanting to get a new
video game.
>>Girl #1: Maybe a new pair of shoes.
>>Boy #2: College money.
>>Girl #2: Wait until Christmas comes and
then buy my sister a really cute outfit. [sound
of a harp]
>>Hyrum Grenny: Clearly, they were all personally
motivated to earn and keep their money, right?
Here's how it worked. Over the course of 10
minutes, they would complete four easy tasks.
After each task, I'd give them 10 dollars
and a chance to spend it, or save it. The
only temptation they'd face is a bunch of
overpriced junk at my Change Anything store.
[music]
[register sounds]
So we've got kids who really want to save.
They only have to resist temptation for 10
minutes and the only temptation they'll get
is obviously a terrible deal. How hard could
this be? Let's see how the first subjects
do.
[music]
>>Singer on Clip: Well it's bye-bye pretty
baby. Pretty baby, bye-bye.
>>Hyrum Grenny: Wait a minute. What happened?
[singer continues in background]
In spite of rip-off prices, these kids were
spending like it’s bonus day on Wall Street.
In fact, this group only saved an average
of 13 dollars. A few of them even went into
debt. What happened to those grand goals to
save money?
[guitar strumming]
>>Girl #2: Snickers is my favorite candy,
I can usually get it at a dollar fifty at
a store, but since it’s my favorite candy.
I bought it for six dollars.
>>Hyrum Grenny: And what about this poor kid?
Ten dollars again.
[bass music]
In the end, all but one of these well-intentioned
savers failed. Why would they pay so much
to pay so little when they only had to wait
ten minutes to achieve their goal?
>>Girl #3: I don't know.
>>Boy #3: I don't know.
>>Girl #4: There was like, a lot of good stuff
to buy.
>>Boy #1: I'm not sure if I can answer that
question.
>>Hyrum Grenny: Sounds like a willpower problem,
right?
>>Girl #5: I paid six dollars for it because
it didn't come any cheaper.
>>Hyrum Grenny: Well not so fast. Picture
it this way. It turns out that I laced their
experience with six powerful sources of influence;
the same kind you and I face in the real world.
And these guys are experts at pulling us in
directions we don't want to go. In fact, each
one of these behavioral bullies worked against
my would-be savers. Here's how.
Everyone got to taste a free sample of their
favorite candy. Yummy. Nobody taught them
how to track their expenses. They were surrounded
by bad examples and negative peer pressure.
>>Girl #6: You know, there's a lot of awesome
candy over there.
>>Boy #5: Dude, you should get a lot; as much
as you can.
>>Hyrum Grenny: They spent from a credit account,
which made the spending feel easy. Just grab
whatever you wanna buy. And finally, there
were lots of enticing pictures on the walls.
I think you adults call that marketing. Wow,
these kids never had a chance.
>>Girl #3: I paid four dollars for this, but
I don't know why.
>>Girl #5: I wish I'd saved more.
>>Hyrum Grenny: But the real problem is bigger
than just being outnumbered six to one. These
kids were blind to all of it. Why do think
it was so hard to save your money?
>>Boy #6: I don't know.
>>Hyrum Grenny: To be sure I could attribute
their disappointment to these sources of influence,
I changed them for the second group. I got
them working for the savers, rather than against
them. No free samples, I taught them how to
track their expenses, I turned accomplices
into helpful friends.
>>Girl #7: I'm going to save my money. How
about you?
>>Boy #5: I think I'm going to save my money.
I think it'd probably be a good idea.
>>Hyrum Grenny: I paid them in cash so they'd
feel immediate loss when they bought something,
and I took down all that marketing mumbo-jumbo.
OK. A new group of kids, with the same jobs,
same pay, and the same opportunity to buy
from my Change Anything store. Now let's see
what happens.
[pause]
Success. These kids walked away with 260 percent
of what the first group saved, but what do
these subjects attribute their success to?
>>Boy #7: I don't know.
>>Boy #8: I don't know exactly, but.
>>Girl #8: Because I'd rather save it so I
can have it later on.
>>Boy #9: I just thought I shouldn't buy any
more because my goal was 30 dollars and I
wanted to keep that goal.
>>Girl #9: I needed the money.
>>Hyrum Grenny: Hmm. Turns out, these kids
were just as blind to the positive sources
of influence as the other kids were to the
negative ones. So, what's the problem with
that? Well, if you don't know why you succeeded,
you won't be able to fix your failures. And
that's just it.
My dad and his colleagues discovered that
there are six sources of influence all around
us, all the time. And they have enough pull
to determine our behavior and therefore, our
results. And if we can't see them, we can't
change them. So when they're working against
us, we're blind, outnumbered, and doomed.
So what's the point?
If we're struggling to change tough habits,
we may not have a willpower problem, but a
math problem. The numbers are simply stacked
against us and we don't even know it. But
if we can learn to see and engage all six
sources of influence on our side, change becomes
almost inevitable. Just think about it.
Getting what we really want out of life. Wouldn't
that be great? And it’s a whole lot better
than the alternative.
>>Boy #10: I didn't want to spend too much
so I could reach my goal. But at the end I
kind of bought a little more. So, yeah.
[music ends]
[end clip]
>>Joseph Grenny: Isn't that remarkable? Did
you catch the difference in the savings amounts
between the two groups? What was the increase
in the second group?
>>Male Audience Member #1: 260 percent.
>>Joseph Grenny: Yeah, 260 percent. This is
remarkable. These aren't subtle little differences.
These aren't small. These are profound differences.
What I want you to do though with your partner
is just articulate, what are the implications
of this for how we think about change? So
just take 60 seconds and what leaps to you
as an implication of this research?
[pause]
[audience members chatting]
All right, sorry to interrupt, but let me
pause you. I wanted to get your wheels turning
on that so we can explore and apply for just
a second. I want you to notice in the experiment
we held willpower constant. So the assumption
is, the willpower capacity of the two groups
was precisely the same. But the outcomes were
entirely different.
The central argument here is that willpower
is not a particularly good predictor of whether
we succeed or fail at change. There's something
else going on. If that's true, then this is
one of the implications. The problem very
often, not all the time, but very often is
not that we're weak. The problem is that we're
outnumbered.
The problem is that it isn't just some magical
rope that there's some invisible opposition
with. There are definable, knowable, identifiable
sources of influence that are on the other
side of that rope, pulling us in the other
direction. The problem is not a willpower
problem. It’s a math problem and it's that
we're secondarily blind to the math problem.
We're overwhelmed by these opposing sources.
So here's the upshot. One of the things that
predicted people's succeeding at changes is
their acknowledgement of that second point.
Those who were in the second cohort, the ones
who succeeded at changing habits, started
to gain an awareness that they had far less
control over their behavior than they like
to tell themselves.
What they did acknowledge though, was that
they could have enormous control over the
things that control them. And that's where
they turned their attention. It was less just
about saying, "grit my teeth, grunt hard,
and pull." It was more about starting to become
a student of what was happening to my own
behavior, learning to appreciate and identify
some of those sources of influence.
So, here's the challenge. It's making the
dynamic move from that, to this. The question
is how do we marshal those same forces on
our side of the rope? And that’s when these
people started to turn the corner. That's
when they were not just marginally more successful
at change. They were ten times more likely
to be able to produce change.
So let me give you a little quick opportunity
to play with the concept. Let's imagine, for
a moment, that you're a sales professional.
And what you've figured out is that if you
start your day hitting some of the toughest
calls that you have to make, your sales increase.
So that's what you ought to do.
You really gotta organize your day so that
you hit the phone right away, making some
of the important contacts for that day. However,
on this particular day, you started your day,
instead of making phone calls, with two hours
of chatting with colleagues, checking out
news websites and organizing your calendar
before starting on your leads.
You ended up blowing the whole morning and
not getting much done. I'm sure programmers
never have this problem, right? So all of
us have felt that same dynamic. And the question
I want you to answer, I'm gonna give you ten
seconds to do it. All I want you to do, is
off the top of your head with your current
brain, answer the question, why?
So why, when he intended to start his day
with all of those great calls, did he instead
fritter it away in the way that I just described?
So turn to your colleague. First answer off
the top of your head, why did it happen?
[pause]
All right. OK, I want you to put a pin in
that answer. I want you to hang onto it for
a second. So let me get one answer. What's
one reason I might have done that?
>>Male Audience Member #2: It was too hard
to make the call. So I delayed it.
>>Joseph Grenny: OK, good. He says, "I put
it off because it’s too hard. It’s not
fun. I don't really wanna do this." What would
be one more reason?
>>Female Audience Member #1: Oh, I said procrastination.
>>Joseph Grenny: OK, good. So I was just procrastinating,
just putting it off. Again, because it's unpleasant.
Let me just get one more. How about from you?
>>Male Audience Member #3: Laziness.
>>Joseph Grenny: Lazy. All right. I was just
too lazy. Now, what I want you to notice and
sorry about the "gotcha," but I want you to
notice that almost all of our explanations
for my failure, fall into what we just call
"The Willpower Trap". What we just did with
our current brains, is explain my behavioral
lapse by saying, "I just didn't want it badly
enough, or I wasn't strong enough to overcome
some of those urges and impulses." Does that
make sense?
That's the problem. That's the problem. When
we try to explain our failures, we do it in
terms of a motivation struggle. Let me broaden
and make this a little bit more complex. What
if it's possible that personal motivation
was an issue? OK? Let's just acknowledge that.
So, it is more fun not doing these calls than
doing them.
So, "Calling leads fills me with anxiety.
Watching kitties fall asleep on YouTube is
fun.
[laughter]
So, I'll do something more pleasurable." Got
it. Well, what if there were also ability
reasons for it? For example, I don't know
how to change the lethargic feeling I have
when I sit down at the computer. Could that
be a skill gap in part? Are there emotional
management skills that I might lack? What
about social?
Is it possible that my colleagues are also
part of the problem? So, they come around
and we have fun together and we laugh and
they encourage that distraction and diversion.
I mean, is that a possible part of the problem
here? What about others who don't just sort
of encourage, but also enable? People knock
on my door.
They send me IMs as I'm psyching myself to
get started. There are positive interruptions
from other human beings. Do you see the problem
here? The problem is far more complex than
just "I didn't want it badly enough." We've
perfectly organized the world to make it so
that you won't. What about incentives?
Turns out for this particular person, when
he makes a big sale, he relaxes for a while.
There's not as much of an economic incentive
to continue pounding the phone because "I
feel OK for the month." And what about structurally?
Notice how few of us identified this one.
It turns out that as I sit at my desk getting
ready to make phone calls, there are five
kinds of distractions that are piped right
into me.
Do any of you ever notice that in your work?
I can get instant messages, texts, mobile
phones, emails. There are a million other
distractions just a click away. We have perfectly
structured our physical environment to create
distraction today. But when you try to explain
why I didn't make my calls, all we tend to
look at is, "Well, you didn't want it badly
enough." That's the point.
That's what we've got to learn to get past.
Here's why. Because when it comes to these
six sources of influence, you literally have
only two choices. You can either act on them.
You can either identify the ones that are
working against you and marshal them in your
favor, or you can be acted on by them. If
you don't do the former, you will experience
the latter.
You will be controlled and shaped by these
to the degree you're not conscious of, and
taking action, to try to move them on your
side. So, point one. Point one is, that we
have to break out of this simplistic model
that we carry in our brains about human behavior
that attributes disproportionately our choices
to willpower, to how bad we want something.
That's an ingredient. But it’s far less
than you might think. Here's the second. The
second big difference between the successes
and the failures were the mode with which
they approached their change challenge. We
call this becoming both the scientist and
the subject. Now you already do this. You're
already pretty good at it, but we don't tend
to do it as systematically as we should.
In fact, I saw a fun, naturalistic example
of this just a while back. This was at Vital
Smarts. I was standing in front of a group
like this. We took a break and I saw an email
come through on my phone and the email said
this. It said, "Hey Everyone! A set of keys
was found in the downstairs refrigerator.
If they are yours, come find Becky." Now this
is Vital Smarts.
I get the sense the Google culture is kind
of similar. I knew that with that kind of
a setup there would be a dozen smart alec
emails that would follow after this one, coming
from people poking fun. So I waited and sure
enough, the first one came through. "Um can
you please tell us whoever it is that claims
than so we can make fun of them? Thanks, Joe."
Sent to all of the employees at Vital Smarts.
What followed this one was, "If you keep them
in the freezer they last longer. Just saying.
Platte."
[laughter]
Very helpful suggestion. Followed by, "it’s
not me-- I only keep my keys in the 2nd or
3rd floor refrigerators. Rob." So as these
are all coming through and I was enjoying
and appreciating them. Then finally, the mystery
was solved.
Emily wrote in. She says, "They are mine.
I put them on my leftovers so I won't forget
to take them home with me at the end of the
day."
[audience chuckles]
Isn't that clever? How many of you do something
like that? How many of you use some sort of
a-- my biggest problem is when I stay at hotels,
I always forget my gym clothes cause they're
hanging over the towel bar in the bathroom,
trying to help them dry out a little bit.
And so a few years ago, I realized "Joseph
is too stupid to remember to get his gym clothes,
so you'd better do something to trick Joseph
into remembering". So I go get a laundry bag
out of the closet, lay it across my garment
bag and that reminds me to go get my gym clothes
and bring them--.
Does that make sense? What we found is that
people who are really good at change start
thinking of themselves like a lab rat. They
start thinking about themselves in the third
person, and saying, “I know a little bit
about me and here's what I have to do to get
me to behave differently than I otherwise
would."
Here's a fun illustration. So one of our six
hundred changers was Sharman Went. Sharman
was struggling to lose 120 pounds. She tried
for 20 years to shed this weight. And she'd
make a little progress and then slip backwards.
And over time, she got so defeated because
of this willpower trap issue that she gave
up.
But then something happened inside of her
and she started looking at herself and learned
a few things about what had caused failures.
And then was able to say, "What might I do
to predict success." Here's one of the conclusions
she drew. She said at the final time when
she approached her weight loss challenge,
she said, "I never promised to always keep
my diet."
She said, "I think that was one of the things
I got wrong. I would make some absolute promise,
and then as soon as I would break it, I'd
feel horrible and depressed. And then I would
give up. So this time I didn't do that." But
then watch what she did.
She said, "I did, however, make an unequivocal
promise to myself that before I broke my diet,
I would read a three by five card that I carried
with me. That was my promise. That's all I
promised. And then after reading that card,
I would make my choice about whether to break
the diet or not." Now, the first thing I want
you to notice is the way she's thinking about
herself as the object of study.
She's carefully working through what the failure
paths were and then starts to say what interventions
would help this person called Sharman to behave
differently in the future. See, here's why
this became so important in these people's
success stories. Because social scientists
may have studied a category of change that
you care about, whether it’s changing your
spending habits, improving a relationship,
advancing your career.
So there are books out there that will say,
"Here's what we know from a study of 2000
people in this category." The problem, however,
is that the idiosyncrasies are more important
than the commonalities. That the differences
between you and that average person that was
studied are more profound than what you have
in common with most of them.
That's the difference between social science
and physical science. And no one has ever
studied you. No one's ever done it. So that
diet book probably doesn't apply 90 percent
to you. That relationship book may not have
a lot to say to you. So you have to do the
research. You have to be the scientist.
You have to do the first ever study of an
in of 1, of a person called "you" and figure
out what is unique and idiosyncratic about
your choices and your behaviors. And how then
would you use that to trick you into behaving
differently. How would you do that? In order,
however, to do that well, you need a model.
You need a way of both understanding as well
as influencing your own behavior.
These changers that we studied eventually
succeeded, but many of them took a few years
to get there. What we hope to contribute with
the "Change Anything" book, is to shorten
that learning cycle, to help people have an
explicit model that they can use to study
their own behavior and therefore, create interventions
that are remarkably successful and remarkably
fast.
And here's the model. So what I'm gonna do
in the remaining time we've got, is fly you
through that. I'm gonna have you play with
it as scientists and I want you to notice
how easy it is to overlook various elements
of the model. Here's the first. The first
element that we often misunderstand or fail
to use is the one that is the trap we fall
into.
So it’s the personal motivation source of
influence. The problem we often have in attempting
to change is that bad habits feel really good
and good habits don't feel very good. Is that
true? So, very often the unhealthy behaviors
are very personally motivating. The question
then that you and I have to ask is, is the
only solution digging in our heels and resisting
those impulses?
Is that the only way to approach this? What
we found is that successful changers almost
never take that tack. They use tactics to
help them literally change how they feel about
both the bad behavior and the good. Let me
share with you a little experiment. I need
you to get with your buddy. So with your partner,
you need to decide who is Person A and who
is Person B. Pick an A and a B.
[audience chatter]
There's no big strategy to this, just a simple
assignment. Go for it. All right? So, all
the Person As. Raise your hand if you're Person
A. OK, good. If you're Person A, you now have
ten dollars in your hand, OK? It’s an imaginary
ten dollars I've given to you. So you have
ten dollars in your hand. Person B, you are
going to get an offer from Person A.
This is called "The Ultimatum Game" in behavioral
economics, if any of you are familiar with
it. So person A is going to offer to split
that ten dollars with you. He or she can offer
you anywhere from zero to ten dollars. After
they make the offer, you are going to either
accept or reject their offer.
So if I offered you one dollar, you could
now either accept or reject it. If you accept
it, you get one dollar, I get nine and we're
done. If he rejects it, neither of us get
anything. We both lose. Does everybody understand
the rules? OK, so Person A, I want you to
decide how much you're going to offer right
now and as soon as I say go, you turn and
make your offer.
And then Person B, I want you to immediately
either accept or reject it, OK? So Person
A, give it some thought. Give it some thought.
Figure it out. What's your offer? OK. Ready,
set, go. Make your offer.
[audience chatter]
OK, good. Accept or reject. All right. How
many of you rejected the offer? Did any of
you reject it? Just got one. How much did
he offer you?
>>Male Audience Member #4: One dollar.
>>Joseph Grenny: One dollar.
[laughter]
No, it’s interesting because a rational
person would do what? What would you do? Accept
or reject a dollar?
>>Male Audience Member #4: Accept it.
>>Joseph Grenny: It's a dollar more than you
would've had a moment ago, right? But something
in us gets us to reject it 'cause you're a
creep, right? For offering my only one dollar.
[laughter]
There's something else going on here, something
value-driven. Now, this is the interesting
experiment that was set up by Lee Ross at
Stanford. We did a replication of this a little
while back in a mall. Had people play the
game. And in that game, we framed it two different
ways. I want you to listen to how subtle and
small these differences were.
In Round 1 of the game, we called it what
you see on the sign here. We said, "You and
your colleague here are going to play the
Wall Street Game. And you are going to decide
how much to offer to your opponent." You follow?
In Round 2, we called it the "Community Game".
"You and your colleague will be playing the
Community Game and you have to decide how
much to offer you partner."
Do you think just changing a couple of words
would change the outcome? Yeah, yeah. It was
remarkable. Sixty percent more people offered
even splits when we just called it the Community
Game. You and I were willing to give up money,
which can feel physically painful to us. We're
willing to surrender money if we just have
a little different mental frame for the choice
that we're making.
It's remarkable. So how does this work? Remember
the problem. Bad habits feel good. Good habits
feel bad. So, how to change is deal with that
problem? Here's what Sharman did. Sharman
promised that before she broke her diet, she
would read a little card. That's all she promised
to do. Now, Sharman's biggest downfall was
chimichangas. Sharman loves chimichangas.
She said she'd be sitting in a restaurant
and would see chimichanga on the menu and
a whole train of mental and physiological
processes would start to take place. Her mouth
would water. She could recall the melted cheese
and the tasty, delicious, soft pork in the
middle of the--. She hadn't even ordered the
thing yet and she's already experiencing the
chimichanga.
So this became her crucial moment. And in
that moment, she said she'd made a promise
that she wouldn't always keep her diet, but
she'd read the card. So she'd retrieve this
three by five card and she would read line
one. Line one said, in her own penmanship,
"I'd like to feel healthier." And then she'd
take a breath and she'd pause.
And then she'd read line two, which said,
"I'd like to like the way I look in the mirror."
And she'd take a breath. And then line three,
"I'd like to have more physical stamina."
Line four, "I'd like to model healthy living
for my grandkids." Line five, "I'd like my
husband to be proud of how I look." She said
somewhere between lines three and four, something
strange would happen inside of her.
She said the chimichanga felt different. She
said somewhere in there, suddenly, she would
not want the chimichanga quite as much as
she did before. Now, this didn't work every
time, but frequently it was the case. She
felt differently towards the chimichanga.
She says, in fact, later on as she worked
with this, she would actually feel disgust
for the chimichanga.
It would feel like a sellout to her. Is that
possible? And not only is it possible, it
was remarkably predictive. Now I want you
to notice what she just did. Not only did
she succeed in losing 120 pounds and has kept
if off now for many years, what she did was
she acted like a scientist studying her, trying
to figure out, "Could I create an intervention
that would change how I felt about my choices
in crucial moments?"
And then she developed one using a tactic
we call "creating a personal motivation statement."
What we describe in the book are 22 different
tactics that people seem to stumble upon.
They eventually discovered that helped them
accomplish things like this. So if we have
professional challenges, we often have habits
and behaviors that are tough for us to change
because they're emotional barriers.
We have emotions we have to change. But the
truth is that it is possible for us to use
little interventions like this to help us
change how we feel, to love what we hate,
to have different feelings towards positive
and negative behaviors. So that's one. The
second area where you have to be a pretty
good scientist is illustrated by this.
So with your partner, I want you to help out
Mary Gordon. Mary Gordon was concerned about
proactive bullying that happened in schools.
So, proactive aggression is defined as, not
just we're mad at each other so we push each
other, but somebody who seeks somebody out
as a victim and targets them for punishment.
So she wanted to try to have an influence
on proactive aggression in schools and in
fact, was remarkably successful in over 12,600
classrooms. So here's what I want you to do.
I want you to turn to your partner and I want
you to come up with one thing that you would
do if you were a school principal to try to
reduce bullying in your school.
How would you get bullies to stop doing that?
One idea. Ready. Set. Go.
[pause]
All right.
[audience chatter]
OK, now. I want you to examine the idea you
came up with. So I don't care about the content
of the idea and you're not gonna be probably
moving anywhere with that. I want you to notice
what category of influence we tend to rely
on. So when we're explaining my ineffectiveness
at making sales calls, we tend to look at
motivation.
I want you to notice if the idea you came
up with had to do with compliance, accountability,
punishment, holding them to--, giving them
some sort of consequence. And what we tend
to do very often, is move in the motivation
direction. And that's not what Mary Gordon
did. Mary brought kids who were struggling
with proactive aggression into a classroom
with a baby, a little infant.
And she taught them skills. She just had them
practice just reading the expressions of the
baby and trying to label how the baby felt.
How is the baby feeling right now? Put a word
to it. She taught them skills for recognizing
and identifying a baby's behaviors. And then
taught them skills for changing a baby's behaviors.
She tried to coach them so that they would
have strategies to try to both understand
other people's emotions and relate to them
in a different way. The consequences of this,
and a number of other interventions, were
remarkable. Eighty-eight percent of those
who had struggled previously with proactive
aggression stopped.
And three years later, stayed stopped. Here's
the point. The point is that new habits almost
always require new skills. The issue here
is that there are emotional, interpersonal,
mental and physical skills that when we're
in the throes of bad habits, we tend not to
develop. But when you and I try to approach
change, we almost never look at the ability
side of the model.
We think it’s primarily a motivation issue
and we run ourselves down that side. So, think
about Michael Vitali, the guy I introduced
to you earlier. Twenty years of drug addiction.
Most of us would say that Michael will finally
give up drugs when he's motivated enough,
when he wants it, when he hits rock bottom,
right? That's the predictor.
Well, baloney. Because it turns out that over
20 years, he had crafted a whole set of skills
that helped him to be an addict. And if I
asked you to make a list, if we had time,
it's an interesting exercise, there are quite
a few. You have to be a world-class liar.
You have to be a pretty competent thief. You
have to be pretty good at identifying drugs
and mixing drugs and negotiating for it.
You're gonna have to work out where you're
going to sleep at different times. He got
really good at dumpster diving over this period
of time and that is a skill. It's an actual
skill. Where would you find food when you
had no money? Over time, he had crafted a
whole set of skills that adapted him perfectly
to a certain lifestyle.
He had none of them for the corollary lifestyle.
Absolutely none. And what you and I do, is
say, "Well, Michael, when you want it badly
enough, you'll succeed over there." No, it
doesn't work like that. What happens is, he
wants it badly enough, he tries, fails, and
then says, "This is the only life I'm competent
for." Well, what about Thomas?
Thomas has a four person production team and
he's not meeting schedules and budgets. He
was fired for those chronic inabilities. What
we know is that there were skill gaps. It
wasn't just "Do you want it badly enough,
Thomas?" It's, "Do you have skills for organizing,
planning, holding people accountable, holding
crucial conversations when necessary, or a
whole variety of things that people who are
good at this tend to be able to do?"
What we know is that any attempt to motivate
the unable doesn't create change. It creates
depression. And you and I tend to approach
change with a motivation first kind of an
approach. Now let me move to the last couple
of categories here very quickly. This is AJ
Wagner. She had a two-pack a day smoking habit
and was struggling to try to change.
And I want you to listen to something that
was common in the narratives of most of these
people.
[plays clip]
>>AJ Wagner: I've always been a daddy's girl.
I spent most of my childhood idolizing my
father, who's a heavy smoker. And [pause]
one of the things I needed to do was limit
my exposure to smoke. And so, our long talks
in a smoking environment were gonna have to
come to a screeching halt. And our long talks
on the phone with both of us on the other
end smoking were going to have to slow down
as well.
And it wasn't a difficult, it was a difficult
process rather. It wasn't easy at all. And
it hurt a little and we tried to maintain
communication. We didn't sever the relationship.
But it was obviously strained for a while.
And there was a lot of question and answer
as I tried to learn how to have a conversation.
And ultimately, we've come through the rough
times.
We speak relatively regularly. We still love
one another. But the relationship had to change
in order to maximize my own personal change
and my own health needs, and the subsequent
health changes that have happened in my husband
and children and, hopefully, grandchildren
in the future.
[end clip]
>>Joseph Grenny: Isn't that interesting? Well,
one of the things that many of them recognized
is that bad habits are a team sport. That
there are almost always other people that
are playing a role in my continuing to behave
the way I do. Some of them may not even be
conscious of the role they're playing. You
don't have to have an agenda to have an influence.
So, what almost all of them experienced was
they had to change the mix of what we call
"accomplices and friends" in their lives.
Accomplices are those who are either enabling
or encouraging the bad habits and the friends
are those who are supportive of the positive
change. Now again, I'm not gonna have any
time to elaborate on this. But I wanna illustrate
how subtle sometimes the social influences
can be.
Bob Mues was struggling to lose about 150
pounds and he didn't even realize that he
should struggle for many, many years because,
well, let me explain why. Here's how he discovered
he shouldn't. One day, he was on Google Earth
and saw a new feature called Google Street
View. And on Google Street View, he said,
"I wanna look at Longwell Green, England and
see my house."
And so he went to his house and he said there
was this looming massive structure in front
of his house that he didn't quite recognize.
He said that the image was grainy enough that
he wasn't sure what and who it was until he
finally recognized, "It's me and I'm huge."
[laughter]
He said it was at that moment when he realized
he could be seen from outer space.
[laughter]
That he thought, "I probably have something
I ought to address here." Very often, you
and I sort of blend into our environment because
those around us are modeling the very behavior
that we're struggling to get out of. He didn't
know he was overweight because everybody around
him was overweight.
Everybody at the pub looked just like he did.
There's a problem today of awareness about
many of our bad habits because there are accomplices
that model things around us. One of the things
that we hope you get out of the book is the
capacity to start differentiating the roles
people play and how to get them on your side
in support of change. Here's the last.
The last category of influence I wanna address,
I'm gonna give you as a problem to help me
solve. So this is one of our changers who's
had his third heart attack. His name is Jim.
Jim was told after his first heart attack
that you need to change your diet or you're
gonna have another heart attack. And he did
for about a week.
And then he started slipping back in the other
direction. And then he had a second heart
attack and he changed his habits again for
about a month. And now he's had his third
heart attack. So he comes to you and he asks
for one piece of advice. How can he help himself
change his eating habits forever?
What's one piece of advice you'd give him
right now off the top of your head? So, share
that with your partner.
[pause]
[audience chattering]
All right. Good. So again, I want you to lock
that in your mind right now. Remember my original
goal was I want us to have a different brain.
I want us to have a different way of thinking
about these problems.
So I want you to notice what category of influence
you just drew upon. So if you had a suggestion
for how to stay motivated, that's a good one.
If you had a suggestion about ability, that's
a good category. If you had a suggestion about
social influence, that's a whole other one.
How do you get people on your side and supportive?
But if you didn't have this category of influence,
we missed one of the most simple ones to go
after. So a colleague of ours, Brian Wansink
at Cornell University, inspired this experiment.
We brought a bunch of kids together, had them
play soccer for an hour and a half until they
were good and hungry. And then afterwards,
brought them in for a wonderful feast of macaroni
and cheese.
We randomly assigned the 14 kids to either
one table or another, as you see. And I want
you to see if you can notice a difference
between the plates. I understand this is common
knowledge at Google. It's a good thing for
you to be aware of. So one table had plates
the size of hubcaps. The other had these petit
little plates about three inches smaller in
diameter. Do you think that would make a difference?
>>Audience Members: Yeah.
>>Joseph Grenny: Yeah. Now I want us not just
to think about plates, though. I want you
to generalize. At the conclusion, we asked
all the kids, "Are you full? Did you get enough
macaroni and cheese?" Every one of the kids
said, "I'm full. I'm happy." They weren't
denying themselves. It wasn't a struggle.
And then we weighed the two bowls to see what
the difference was in consumption.
One table ate 73 percent more than the other
table and both groups of kids reported being
equally full. Now here's the problem. We learned
something about plates, but we don't generalize
it. So Thomas understood that his physical
environment affected his relationships and
therefore, his ability to hold people accountable
and finish his work on time.
In his subsequent job, he became a scientist.
He began trying to apply that knowledge to
his own behavior. So what did he do? He started
changing where he ate lunch. He started eating
where his colleagues ate. That changed the
quality and strength of his relationships.
That helped him deal with issues a little
bit more effectively with them.
What you gotta learn to do is control your
space. Now the problem is that very often,
we're blind to the effect our physical environment
has on our choices. Do you catch the irony?
[laughter]
Yeah. This is from Google Street View probably,
here. Most of us riding the escalator up are
unconscious of the fact that I'm about to
go stand on a treadmill for 45 minutes. I
mean, where's the sense in this? Our physical
environment suddenly and invisibly shapes
our choices. So what do you have to learn
to do? You gotta learn to see it.
You gotta learn to see ability gaps, social
influence, structural influences. If you use
tools and fences, cues, autopilots, distance,
there are things we can do in changing our
environment. The best piece of advice you
could have given Jim about his third heart
attack, is get smaller plates. Use smaller
spoons.
Make some physical changes because it immediately
affects our choices. And it isn't just around
consumption. It's around every category of
influence that we need to go after. So what
do we have to learn to do? We've gotta develop
tactics that help us deal with personal motivation
challenges. You better address ability gaps.
You better get social influence working on
your side. You better deal with incentives.
That's a category we didn't address today.
You better deal with the physical environment
and how it affects your choices. That's what's
causing us to fail. Most of us know we should
change, want to change, but don't change.
And we're hoping that access to this kind
of science helps us to understand a little
bit more of our own choices and take control
of those.
So, thank you very much. I got a couple more
minutes for questions and will be happy to
address anything you got and I appreciate
you being here today.
[applause]
Any questions or comments? Happy to entertain
anything you got. Yes.
>>Male Audience Member #6: Do you think, in
large part, our economy is based on people
not understanding these principles?
>>Joseph Grenny: Yeah. He says is the economy
in large part based on people not understanding
these principles. I think so. But the people
who do understand them are the people trying
to exploit that opportunity. So the economy
is perfectly organized now to help us be subject
to a lot of these sources of influence and
unless we're armed the same way, it's an unfair
fight. And I think that's an important point.
Other questions? Yes.
>>Male Audience Member #7: Is it just as difficult
to see the good influences as the bad influences?
>>Joseph Grenny: Say again?
>>Male Audience Member #7: Is it just as difficult
to see the good influences as the bad influences?
>>Joseph Grenny: Yeah, this is an insightful
question. He says is it just as difficult
to see the good influences as the bad influences.
I did a lecture on this a little while back
and a woman said, "Well, I quit smoking and
I just went cold turkey and it was all willpower."
And I said, "Congratulations. That's great
to hear."
And after hearing more about the model, she
said, "Oh, I now realize that the fact that
my husband quit smoking a month before me
may have helped. The fact that my workplace
went smoke-free about two months before that
and I had to smoke outside in a freezing cold
Kansas winter may have helped." She started
going through one after another and started
seeing what had been going on that she had
been the beneficiary of.
So I think you're absolutely right because
if we don't learn from our successes, we can't
fix our failures. So, very important part
of what we're trying to help advance.
[pause]
Looks like we're at one o'clock. Thank you
very much. It was great to spend time with
you.
[applause]
Good luck.